so hello everyone uh thank you so much
for joining us um my name is petra
parecova i am the associate director for
our computer science and artificial
intelligence programs at stanford center
for professional development and it's my
big pleasure today to you know be
joining dan bonnet
in his talk and about the science of
blockchains so thank you so much dan
once again for joining us
for a quick introduction for those who
who don't know dan but hopefully you all
do because you know he's our great
speaker and we shared a little bit of
information beforehand he is the
professor of computer science and
electrical electrical engineering at
stanford uh he's also the head of the
applied cryptographic group and he
co-directs the computer security lab
and professor bona's research focuses on
applications of cryptography uh to
computer security and he's basically
like the person you want to hear about
blockchain from so we are very glad that
he was able to join us
and i think that we will kick us uh off
uh maybe if you have some questions
don't hesitate to use the
q a box you will find on your console uh
we will make sure that we ask some
questions at the end uh we will try to
get to as many as we can so i think
that's it thank you so much then once
again uh you can get started
okay thank you petra uh so welcome
everyone it's wonderful to be here um
and let's get started
so what i want to talk about today is a
little bit of what we call the science
of blockchain which is kind of the
technology behind behind blockchains and
i'll tell you about some of the work
we're doing and kind of what i find
exciting in the space
so let's get started
the first thing i want to do is kind of
zoom out a little bit and kind of talk
about traditionally what cryptography
has been about so in kind of uh the i've
been working in cryptography for for a
long time as petra mentioned and it's
interesting that traditionally
cryptography has been um has primarily
had uh
you know one primary customer which was
really the internet and it was
interesting is if you look at
cryptography on the internet what it was
used for was primarily for securing
communication right so if i send my
credit card to amazon i want to make
sure that nobody can steal my credit
card on its way to amazon
so traditionally cryptography sort of on
the internet primarily focused on what
we call confidentiality how do i send
messages across the internet so no one
can eavesdrop and no one can tamper with
those messages so this raises
cryptographic uh mechanisms this uses
cryptographic mechanisms like encryption
key exchange
and things like that
what we've seen with blockchains is that
all of a sudden cryptography now has a
new customer yeah these blockchains are
basically a huge consumer of
cryptographic technology
which is why it's so much fun to work in
the space
but what's interesting is that
blockchain cryptography is a little bit
different from internet cryptography so
on the blockchain as you know most data
is just available in the clear right
we're not encrypting anything when you
write transactions to the ethereum
blockchain the transactions are just
written
in the clear what we care about is not
confidentiality but rather we care about
integrity so really we look about
blockchain cryptographic primitives by
and large we look at things like
signatures commitments zero knowledge
proofs these are all integrity
mechanisms to prove that the data is
valid not so much about encrypting the
data so it's been very interesting to
see that sort of the cryptography that's
used on blockchain is somewhat different
from the cryptography that's used on the
internet and as a result that led to a
wealth of kind of new problems to work
on and new things to think about but
more generally i want to kind of mention
that
there's this whole area which we call
the science of blockchains so science of
blockchains is is i use that term to
differentiate it from what traditionally
is called blockchains which you kind of
hear all the new all the noise about in
the press the science of blockchains is
sort of the technology that underlies uh
all these blockchain systems and it's an
incredible collection of fields um
in particular there are lots of research
questions that are
being raised by the science of
blockchains and economics and
distributed systems of course and
cryptography and programming languages
verification and so on and so forth so
it's a kind of a
collection of
super interesting
areas and you know i have to say it's
been a it's it's the fact that i don't
think that there's ever been one area
that kind of connects all the areas that
are listed here into kind of one
discipline and that's kind of what makes
this kind of a fun area to work in i
have to say that from my experiences
the community is a very welcoming
community if you have good ideas in any
of these areas people are very eager and
interested in collaborating with you and
maybe even deploying what you are what
you propose so it's kind of a very
friendly community community and it's
been kind of a lot of fun to work in the
space so what i want to tell you a
little bit about today is basically sort
of um
kind of where i see this piece going and
we'll talk a little bit about our work
before we do that i do want to mention
that because of this kind of
confluence of scientific areas
at stanford we created this stanford
center for blockchain research it's
called cbr the center for blockchain
research um there's a bunch of faculty
involved in it as you can if you look at
the list you can see they're from sort
of all over the university um focused on
sort of the uh again the underlying
technology behind blockchains and again
it's been a lot of fun to collaborate
with with all these folks and um
we run a lot of activities which are
open to the public all of you are
welcome to attend in particular at the
end of august we're running we're
running the fifth science of blockchain
conference um this is a free open
conference for anyone to attend if you
go to the if you just search for the
science of blockchain conference you'll
find the website right away you can
register and uh and and come if you'd
like we also run seminars so you can
join our mailing list to hear about
seminars and you know again these are
free and open to the public so we're
very happy uh if you uh if you'd like to
attend any of those
i also wanted to mention very briefly
that we run a bunch of uh
classes technical classes on blockchains
on campus uh so the classes are our kind
of introductory introduction to
blockchains uh which is called cs351 in
fact that's a class that's starting in
in a month and a half um i think this is
the class that petra mentioned again
this is uh televised you can take it
remotely if you're interested in joining
uh in the winter we teach our
cryptography class and in the spring we
teach a consensus a class specifically
on on consensus maybe i wanted to just
drill in for just a second and tell you
about the the blockchain class um
so by the end of this class kind of the
goal is to teach the students how
blockchains work if they need to they
can kind of even build their own
blockchain but primarily they should
learn how to run how to write blockchain
applications applications that are run
on top of a blockchain i kind of listed
the topics here i don't think i'm going
to go through them very very carefully
here you can see them on the website all
the information is available on the
course website um we spend there's quite
a lot of interest in zero knowledge
proofs and proof systems in general and
their applications to blockchain so it
can end the second half of the course we
spend quite quite a lot of time on that
um so if you're interested in learning
about any of these topics and learning
how to build your own blockchain
applications you're very welcome to uh
to take the classes available to be
taken remotely as i said okay so
with that let's let me switch gears and
talk about sort of what i wanted to talk
about which is i guess we'll start with
a kind of an overview of what
blockchains are i'm just i'm not sure
what everybody's background is so i
wanted to start uh from the beginning
and kind of tell folks how i view
blockchains and then we'll talk about
some um some of our uh some of our
recent work
okay so what is a blockchain for what is
it good for so the short answer that i
usually give is that blockchains really
are kind of a way for um for a large
number of people to coordinate when
there isn't a trusted party isn't a
single trusted party that everybody
trusts the corollary of this of course
is if there is a single trusted party
typically you actually don't need a
blockchain yeah and so for example if
everybody is happy to use i don't know
google as a trusted party there's no
need for a blockchain you can just use
the google systems the google databases
and store all your data there and
everybody's happy if there's a
government that everybody trusts then
you could just use government services
there's no need for a blockchain in
those cases
but if you're an environment where
actually you don't want to be beholding
to a single party that's kind of where
blockchains might be useful and
that's where they typically live
now
there are currently sort of four
application areas that blockchains have
been have been useful for yes these are
four applications where they seem to be
a good fit maybe in the future we'll see
more but for now there are there are
these particular four application areas
so let's go through these uh slowly
the first one i'm sure you're all
familiar with is what's called defy
decentralized finance this is basically
this is the use of blockchains for uh
the payment system yeah payment systems
and all the financial uh assets that uh
that go with that i think this is you
guys are pretty
fairly fairly familiar with what defy is
i don't think i want to get into too
much details here the second application
area is what i call managing managing
digital assets in general any digital
asset be it art or sports cards or any
sort of thing that you want uh any sort
of digital asset that you want to
maintain ownership of and
you want to prove provenance and
originality of you can kind of manage on
a blockchain often this is these are
called nfts and it turns out there's
actually a good reason why you want to
manage these things on a blockchain i'll
talk about that a little bit later
so nfds
and more generally digital assets are
kind of the second application area for
blockchains the third application area
is basically games and it's quite
interesting that uh there's a large
fraction of the gaming industry that's
starting to use blockchains now in
traditional games and again the idea is
to sort of manage game assets on a
blockchain so if you
win a sword in a particular game that
the fact that you own that sword is
recorded on a blockchain and no one can
take it away from you unless you give it
away and the fourth application area is
what i call decentralized organizations
daos maybe the easiest way to explain
what a dao is
is just to think of the real world
analog and the real world analog is
basically sort of a partnership yeah so
a bunch of people come together they
want to take they want together to make
decisions on how to manage assets how to
manage uh funds and so on so they can
form this dao and together vote and
decide on what the dao does and there
are many types of dows we'll talk about
those in just a minute that was for
investments for charity for collecting
art and so on and so forth and one of
the interesting questions is basically
how does governance work that is how
does the group that um
the group of members of the dao how do
they actually make collective decisions
and there's a lot of active research
going on here and again this is kind of
one of the topics i wanted to talk about
today in greater depth
okay so those are kind of the four
application areas you know maybe there
will be more in the future you know so i
kind of would challenge you to think
about other application areas where um
where the technology would would be a
good fit and you know maybe maybe next
year when we give this webinar the list
will be will be longer but these are
kind of the current four applications
for application areas that that we
currently see
okay
so let's go back to the beginning and
just talk a little bit about what is the
new capability that blockchain is
enabled yeah what is it about it's not
like what what why did it happen now why
did it happen you know 20 years from now
why didn't it happen 30 years ago and so
on
so it turns out of course as you know
the first blockchain that came up came
out is called the bitcoin blockchain in
2009 and what's interesting about about
bitcoin is not
the fact that it introduced the bitcoin
currency that's sort of a derivative of
what bitcoin did
really kind of the new capability that
bitcoin gave us is sort of something we
didn't have before which is what i call
in a public append only data structure
right so it's a data structure where
anyone can write to that data structure
and anything that's written to that data
structure will stay in that data
structure and can never be removed at
least in principle that's the idea
behind
what bitcoin bitcoin gave us okay so
it's an append only data structure that
anyone can write to and once you write
something to it it'll never be removed
how do we secure that data structure
well how do you build such a thing well
you build it basically by replicating
the data structure across many many
different machines and the minute you
start replicating a data structure
across many different machines you start
to get problems of um of uh consistency
how do we know maybe one machine has one
version of the data structure and
another machine has a different version
of the data structure how do we know
which one is the correct one and so
that's exactly where the consensus
problem comes from which is how do we
replicate a data structure across the
entire planet and make sure that all the
replicas are actually in sync
so security is done by replication and
more importantly by incentives so
everybody's incentivized to actually
make sure that the data structure
actually satisfies the property that it
claims to satisfy once you have such a
data structure you can actually use it
to to uh build the currency right so if
i have an append only data structure and
let's say that i want to pay five
dollars to petra i can record that
transaction on the data structure and no
one can remove the fact that the payment
was made yeah once it's recorded it will
stay there forever this is why sort of
um a currency a cryptocurrency was a
very natural application for this data
structure but i do want you to think
about the data structure as the primary
thing that bitcoin gave us uh the
currency is sort of uh is enabled by
this by this uh data structure
so that's bitcoin the next big big
evolution in the space there have been
many ideas in the space but the next big
step in the space is the development of
ethereum back in 2015 which introduced
what we call the blockchain computer
it's a fully programmable environment
where you can run arbitrary applications
i have to say that in our course we kind
of go um and and talk quite a lot you
know we do quite a lot of hands-on
experiments with building programs that
run on the blockchain on this blockchain
computer um these programs are written
in a language called solidity which i
imagine many of you are familiar with
it's kind of a fun program programming
language to write in uh it's always
interesting to uh to write applications
in in this language what's interesting
is it's quite difficult to make sure
these applications are secure so
i have a lot of stories i can tell there
but
maybe we'll move on for now and so uh
yeah so ethereum introduced this idea of
a blockchain computer so these are
public programs
anyone can inspect the code and they can
manage digital and financial assets yeah
that's what these kind of programs do
one the other interesting aspect of
ethereum is that they were very
concerned with composability which means
that
that different programs running on the
ethereum blockchain can actually call
one another so if i develop something
useful and somebody else wants to use it
their program can just call my program
so this was again a very important idea
that came out in an ethereum so of
course as you all know the story once
the ethereum came out um after after
that we saw the growth of of these four
application areas basically d5 nfts
gaming endows and uh there's been
tremendous growth in the space and kind
of that's kind of where we uh where we
are now
all right so this is kind of a quick
overview of kind of the core ideas that
enabled these blockchains and um there's
this kind of statistic that this is
graph that i want to share that i find
this graph really interesting about
where the development effort is being
spent these days so this is a graph
that's due to electric capital and what
it does if you look at the x and y axis
um so the x-axis basically measures the
days the number of days since the
project
basically launched since the first
commit um
uh so yes so once since the project was
born so you can see bitcoin is the
oldest blockchain which is why it's
furthest to the right to the right and
the y-axis basically measures the number
of developers who work on the project
there's people who commit code
relating to this project either building
applications on top of it or
contributing directly to the uh to the
blockchain itself and it's really quite
interesting if you look at the entire
space there's roughly 20 000 developers
worldwide that worked work in the space
so 20 000 developers that's kind of a
not a small number of developers um but
you can see for example the number of
developers for the work on bitcoin is
somewhat stabilized the number of
developers who work on ethereum
continues to grow this is kind of where
a lot of the development
activity is taking place you can see so
the sort of the up and coming
blockchains there's polka dot over here
cosmos over here um maybe someone over
here uh you can kind of see um
the the next level of um of blockchains
as they grow and the numbers are kind of
interesting right so if you look at
ethereum there are roughly 4 000
developers right now building ethereum
applications for polka dot there are
1500 developers and so on and so forth
it's a very interesting graph to show
that um the level of activity and the
other interesting fact here is you can
see that kind of during um
you know during during what's often
called winter periods you can see the
number of developers is kind of this
area of the graph here the number of
developers stays roughly roughly the
same and then during growth periods the
number of developers kind of uh grows
dramatically so it's very interesting
how this kind of tracks the uh the
ecosystem overall but anyhow it's of
course useful to see where developers
spend their time because probably that's
um that's an indication of where uh
where you know where all the activity is
so i like this graph it's an interesting
very informative graph
okay
so the next thing i want to do is just
talk very briefly about how blockchains
work and then and then i want to switch
gears and talk about the particular
topic that i'd like to talk about today
so in my mind blockchain is sort of
divided into four layers yeah at the
bottom layer we have what we call the
consensus layer that makes sure that all
the replicas of the data structure
they're all in sync with one another
on top of the consensus layer often we
have a scalability mechanisms as you
know
there's a big scalability issue with
popular blockchains in particular in
ethereum because it's so popular there
are so many transactions being submitted
to the ethereum blockchain that the
price per transaction sometimes gets to
be quite high and so there's a need for
for scaling these layer one block chains
so often there's a scalability mechanism
that runs on top of the blockchain uh
these are called layer two systems and
you know roll ups are kind of the
typical examples of that maybe if we
have time we'll talk about how rollups
work in a bit more detail towards the
end of the talk um but that's basically
the consensus layer to make sure all the
replicas are in sync with one another
and whatever is written to the to the
data structure stays there and is never
removed
above the consensus layer we have the
compute layer which is actually what we
call the blockchain computer an example
of that is the ethereum virtual machine
the evm right this is this is the
operating system on top of which all the
applications run
so on top of the blockchain computer we
have applications that that developers
build right so students in the class for
example uh build a lot of um evm
applications a lot of these
decentralized applications dapps
and they run on top of the evm computer
that's provided by the ethereum compute
layer and then on top of the
applications we have the user interface
layer which is basically the thing that
allows end users to actually interact
with applications that run on top of the
computer okay so i kind of think of a
blockchain as divided into these uh into
these four layers um and so if you look
at the picture in a slightly more detail
you can see the blockchain computer
basically manages a lot of unchained
states yeah so there's a lot of storage
this is actually the data structure
where things run
so the computer manages a lot of
on-chain state
these applications run on this computer
and then when an end user wants to
interact with an application typically
they'll interact with a cloud service
traditional cloud service hosted at
amazon or or google the cloud service
will have a copy of the state that's
stored on the blockchain so the state is
stored both on the blockchain and in the
cloud although the authoritative
authoritative source for the data is
whatever is stored on the blockchain
this is sort of the the copy that's
stored in the cloud is more of a cache
that's just used for accelerating
operations and then end users will issue
instructions uh and interact with the
blockchain application through the uh
through this uh through this interface
now what's interesting is actually
interacting with the with the blockchain
turns out to be um somewhat complicated
so there's entire companies uh like in
for an alchemy that are devoted
basically to making it easier to
interact with uh with these applications
so keep in mind if you're gonna build
something most likely you won't be
talking to an application on the
blockchain yourself you'll probably be
talking through an
intermediary uh and those are those are
available as well
okay so that's kind of how these things
work and i guess the last thing maybe
the last general thing i'll say is this
question of why do we even need to
decentralize
applications why do we want
decentralization in the first place so
it's kind of um really quite important
to understand that the descent
decentralization is not a goal on its
own the centralization the
centralization is sort of a means to an
end goal and so what is the end goal
well so you can think of the end goal is
basically making it very easy for apple
for people to deploy their own
applications for example if you wanted
to deploy an application on a bank
system or an existing social network
well if the bank has a competing service
they might refuse to deploy your
application on their infrastructure
because they don't want you to compete
with them
in a blockchain environment actually
there is no there is no such thing
anyone can deploy anything they want and
no one can prevent you from deploying
your application on the on the
blockchain
uh if things were stored in a
centralized system if things were stored
in a centralized database you know
basically the users are are stuck in
some sense with whoever controls that
database um you know in a in a
decentralized environment uh you know
the data is written replicated all over
the world there's no one person that
owns all this data so if for some reason
you're using a service and you're not
happy with the service that they give
you you can just take your data and move
and move elsewhere yeah so those are
kind of the benefits that come from um
from having this this this blockchain
architecture and finally i guess i'll
say that one is regional the other one
tends to be global but i'll skip that i
think the mo the most important thing is
that anyone that no one can prevent you
from
deploying a service anyone can deploy
whatever they want whatever program they
want on these blockchain systems and
then it's up to the public to decide
whether they want to use what was
deployed or or not
all right so i'll leave it at that this
is kind of what i wanted to say at a
high level and now let's kind of
dig a little deeper into uh how dials
work and in particular i want to talk a
little bit about what a private dao is
so in the past couple in the past year
or so we've been working on this concept
of a private dao so um let me tell you a
little bit about that so first of all
let's start with what is a dao yeah so
again so daos stand for decentralized
organizations the idea is that a dao is
literally just an application it's a
decentralized application that's
deployed on a chain at a specific
address so it's really just a program
it's not even a very big program it's
like a typical dows or like a thousand
thousand lines of code that are deployed
on uh say the ethereum blockchain
and then once the contract is deployed
once the dao is deployed it's deployed
at a specific address anyone in the
world can actually send funds to the
dial treasury and contribute to uh to
the town become basically a member of
the dao by doing that
now once so as you can see kind of the
dao builds a treasury the dow typically
has a particular goal in mind we'll see
that in just a minute and then once the
dow is deployed anyone can deploy funds
to the dow treasury and once they deploy
once they become kind of members of the
dow they can also submit proposals as to
what to do with the dow treasury and
more generally you can submit proposals
on how to manage the dow how governance
should work um as we said what to do
with the treasury whether to accept
particular members or not and so on and
so forth so anyone can submit proposals
the participants in the dow votes on
these proposals and once the proposal is
approved basically the proposal executes
and again there are many are many uh
infrastructures available out there for
uh for managing proposals for managing
these proposals snapshot is a very
common one for managing votes and
proposals off-chain so anyone can submit
a proposal to snapshot
then the members can vote
and if the vote
is approved then the proposal actually
executes
okay good all right so um
so today basically if you look on
snapshot you'll see there are thousands
of those already deployed there's
something like 6 500 already today
possibly even more so it's actually uh
quite a popular thing many dials have
been uh have been uh come come into
existence
uh excuse me um and so let's see what
they're for so one type of dao was what
we call a collector dao yeah collector
dao is one that collects various uh
chair
various arts maybe contributes to uh to
fashion and other things so examples are
pleaser dao flamingo doubt flamingo is a
fashion dial for example they contribute
to uh fashion artists um constitution
dao is a nice example constitution dao
is a dao that wanted to buy a physical
copy of the constitution so they would
collect that particular uh that
particular uh physical piece
um and you can see for example uh
pleasure dao uh is is a dow that
collects art you can go look at their
gallery and see all the all the art
pieces that they've already that have
already bought
yeah so again uh people join the dow
they together decide what uh what art
pieces they want to buy um they decide
what to bid on those art pieces and once
the decision is made they go ahead and
execute and and by if they're successful
in the auction they buy the uh the art
piece
so please without for example just to
drill in for a second they have about a
hundred members you can see these
members manage the treasury of the dow
it also has full-time employees yes so
think about that
you have a contract a program running on
the blockchain that has a full-time
employees so these employees salaries is
paid by a program running on a
blockchain which is kind of kind of
interesting together they deliberate
over telegram whether they want to
acquire a particular piece what to what
to bid for that piece and then once they
reach a decision they go ahead and use
the dow treasury to bid and to buy the
piece so it's very interesting how this
works it literally works like a
partnership where they make decisions
together
and jointly uh use the dollar treasury
so that's one example of a doubt another
example of that was what's called a
charity dao and uh one of my favorite
charity dials is called git coin which
actually supports the development of
open source software so git coin has
about 42 000 members they've raised you
know
without treasury is substantial and then
these these members basically make
proposals to uh decide which open source
projects to support using the treasury
that they raised so i wanted to give you
one example here is proposal number 21.
uh so here they look to spend whatever
they look to spend a portion of on the
treasury on some mmm that's a marketing
uh campaign or so yeah and you can see
you can actually track this proposal you
can see exactly the rate at which which
votes were collected so this is the
voting pattern on this proposal the line
indicates when enough votes were
collected for the proposal to pass um
and so you can see that as soon as the
line was reached the proposal passed and
could be executed but people kept on
voting what's interesting is that in on
for this particular proposal only eight
percent of the dao members actually
participated we'll talk more about that
in just a second the participation rate
is relatively low in this type of
governance
um and then the proposal got executed
you can see exactly you know the
ethereum block number where the funds
were actually spent so you can kind of
track exactly from the moment the
proposal was issued
to when it was voted on to to when it
passed and to when it actually executed
on chain and the funds were actually
spent yeah all of this is completely
completely visible so charity dials are
another category of dallas but there are
many others there are what are called
protocol dials dows that are used to man
to govern and manage protocols unispot
for example has 20 29 000 members
compound dao has 4 000 members and and
so on and so forth so again they vote on
how to manage these these systems
there are
social dials which i won't talk about
here there are investment dows which
also i won't talk about here so there
are many many categories of these dows
and there's actually actually quite a
lot of infrastructure that has evolved
around the management of these doubts
so one question that's kind of
interesting is how does governance
actually work and that is you know who
can vote how do you vote
what the exact voting mechanism is how
much does your vote count for there are
lots of governance questions around this
if you're interested in the governance
questions on dao dals which is actually
really quite a beautiful beautiful
question there's a nice paper that just
came out
by by one of our cbr members andy hall
in collaboration with porter smith for
our andy hall is one of the members of
our center so
this andy hall is actually a political
scientist who's very much interested in
the man in the governance of dao's for
political scientists dao's are like um
an amazing uh playground because they
get to use all their theories and see
how governance how those theories affect
governance on daos so they wrote this
paper on basically how daoz can learn
from what's been learned in the last ten
thousand years of human human governance
quite an interesting read so i highly
recommend
highly recommend reading this if you're
interested in how governance works
and generally what what dows are they
basically provide a wonderful platform
for experimenting with lots and lots of
governance mechanisms so for political
scientists this is like a uh
okay
so uh one thing that
i wanted to mention is against the
typical governance method what's called
the one token one vote yeah so for every
token that i own i get to count on votes
this is very similar to how uh votes
work in the stock market right if i own
stocks in a company and the company runs
a vote then the more stocks i have the
more weight my vote carries yeah so
basically members receive tokens and
then they can vote using their tokens
and you can see on proposal 21 that we
just saw you can see how the different
members voted here you can here you can
look at this
at this graph here and you can see here
is someone
some people have many tokens so their
vote actually has carries a lot of
weight other people have fewer tokens uh
and so on these governance tokens are
actually implemented using what's called
open zeppelin's governor's contract
again this is just
relatively simple to learn the code you
can just look it up and see exactly how
the governance mechanism works here i
pasted in the cast vote function so when
you want to vote literally what happens
is
someone calls the cast vote functions on
chain with the proposal id the voter uh
you know whether the support or they not
support the the uh the proposal and the
reason for their decision um and so you
can just look at the code and see
exactly how it works and what it does
it's fairly fairly simple code
the problem though with these kind of
governance mechanisms is this is what we
call a direct democracy right everybody
votes on every proposal and what we've
learned is that the direct democracy
even the greeks already knew this direct
democracy doesn't scale very well to
large populations
so in fact if you look at the uh
participation rate in different uh in
different dials in a different votes
you'll see that the participation rate
is actually quite low so here we have a
graph that we generated this is by the
way based on joint work uh by myself and
andy hall with uh two wonderful students
who are collecting this data what this
shows what this graph shows you is
basically um a number of dowels out
there kind of very very famous dials for
example bitcoin compound and others and
it shows you the average particip
average voting rate for each proposal so
you can see that for compound bitcoin
you know pull together in a swap the
participation rate is under five percent
yeah so not too many people are voting
on the different proposals for some
reason nouns is able to do better you
know participation rate is around 17
up but still you'd like it to be much
much much higher than that and uh right
now using the governance mechanism is
being used the participation rate is
simply not high enough so what do we do
well these governor mechanisms actually
support a delegation mechanism where
you for example rather than voting
yourself on every proposal you can
delegate your coins to somebody else and
they will vote on your behalf yeah so
this is intended to increase
participation support and in fact
government contracts uh supports
delegation so just as an example if we
look at elements this is how the
delegates in element are distributed and
you can see there's one address here i
actually don't know who this address
belongs to but you can see there's one
address here that um 300
other voters delegated their tokens to
this address and so this address now can
vote and has quite a lot of power when
it's actually voting yep so you can see
how delegation actually works it seems
to be
you know a good design we know
representative democracy is kind of how
things work and delegation is a step
towards representative democracy but
there could be many other governance
mechanisms that um that are deployed and
all of those are sort of being
experimented on with uh in the context
of doubts
all right
so what i wanted to do is uh tell you a
little bit a little bit about some
recent work that we did on this question
of private dows in particular i'll talk
about uh a private dow treasury so the
story here this is kind of a fun story
so the story begins with the
constitution doubt so what is the
constitution dao i hope many of you have
heard of the constitution now it's kind
of a remarkable
story of what happened so basically in
2021 there was a copy of the physical
copy of the constitution of the united
states that was made available for for
for sale yeah so there's i think there's
a couple there's like 10 copies of the
constitution available and one of them
was put for auction um at sotheby's and
anyone can bid
so
when that happened the constitution dial
formed
and it was quite remarkable within five
days or so this dow basically was able
to raise 46 million dollars to bid on
the us constitution this money was
raised from around 20 000 participants
from all over the world yeah
this again shows the power of dao's
running on a blockchain that really you
have you can reach anyone in the world
people will contribute funds for a
particular cause um you know
i'm not exactly sure how you would get
20 000 participants to contribute funds
without a blockchain black architecture
and so this is kind of a good fit for
this technology so this constitution
that raised those funds and now it was
ready to bid for uh for the constitution
so they were actually able to make their
bid
it turned out that that they had to
reserve some funds for managing the
constitution itself if they won the uh
the auction and so the highest bid they
could bid if i remember correctly was
around 42 million dollars right so they
could only bid 42 million and the
remaining 4.3 million uh were needed to
manage the constitution if they won the
bid
well so it turns out that uh somebody
else actually
somebody else wanted the constitution
more and they lost to another bidder who
bid 43 million right so this was more
than the constitution thou could bid and
as a result they lost the bid they lost
the auction and they did not win the uh
the constitution
uh you know the physical copy of the
constitution so if you step back for a
second and you ask yourself well what
just happened here you realize that
something actually went very wrong yeah
the problem here is that everything
about the constitution dao was managed
on on a public blockchain as a result
everybody knew exactly what their
treasury was and everybody knew exactly
what is the maximum bid that they could
offer
and as a result the bidder who wanted to
outbid them knew exactly how much they
should bid in order to outbid the
constitution down yeah it's because
because of the public nature of the
blockchain that they could not
participate in this in this auction in
in a fair way in a way that would
actually not reveal what their maximum
possible bid was
so as a result they lost they lost the
auction so the question is basically how
can a how can a public dow that runs on
a blockchain how can it participate in
an auction when everybody knows uh it's
complete treasury everybody knows
exactly how much what's the maximum
amount that it can get so this is a very
interesting question i'd say that in
some sense you know the auction house
you know should have anticipated this
and maybe they should have changed the
rules of the auction to be more friendly
to uh to these public dows
but you know we we i think we live and
learn and hopefully this will not happen
things we'll do will go better next time
but nevertheless it raises this
interesting question of can we build a
dao
that has a private treasury so the world
that looks at the dao doesn't actually
know how much uh funds
it has so you wouldn't know what is the
maximum bid that the tr that the dao can
issue
so this is what we worked on this is
with one of my former students
um yeah um uh the knife and so let me
explain uh how this works so the idea is
basically to have uh a single dial
platform that's going to manage many
many different dials yeah so for example
there are such platforms juice box is an
example of such a platform so many dials
will actually run on the juicebot
juicebox platform it's a single ethereum
contract that manages a large number of
dowels
now when someone wants to contribute
actually when someone wants to create a
dao we'll call that the dao manager they
create the dao and all they do is they
basically publish a public key some some
you know short key which we'll call a
public key they publish that on the
dao's website and they tell people
whenever you contribute to my dow just
use this public key
now when a contributor wants to send
funds to the dow what they'll do is
they'll send funds to the contract the
contract manages
many many different dials and they'll
use a blinded version of the dow public
key so that when you look at the actual
transaction you have no idea which dow
on the contract is the one that's
receiving the funds you'll know that
some dow on the contract receives the
funds but you wouldn't know which one
okay and so every contributes
contributes their funds to the dao in
this blinded way so nobody really knows
which dow has what treasury
so an observer will see the total funds
that are available on the
nadao platform but they wouldn't know
how much what how much treasury each
individual dow had
so the hope is that this would make it
so that it's not possible to tell for
example how much funds the constitution
now has and as a result someone who
wants to outbid them would not know how
much to bid to outbid the constitution
down okay so that's the idea and then
later on when the dow manager actually
wants to withdraw their funds and
participate in the auction they can use
their secret key to withdraw those funds
and they can only withdraw funds that
were submitted to uh to the particular
dial that they manage okay so that's
kind of the idea for how the system
works so the contributions are blinded
and even though they're blinded so the
public doesn't know where they went but
even though they're blinded the dow
manager can later withdraw the funds
that were sent to that dao and cannot
draw funds that were sent to any other
guy
if you're interested in the details of
how this work we at works we actually
have a blog post that we wrote about
this it's kind of a fun design kind of a
nice cryptographic trick to make this
this all work so i would encourage you
to kind of maybe look at
the details of the system
okay so this is kind of uh how we build
a dial with the private treasury but it
turns out there are many other privacy
questions around dowse for example maybe
people want to participate in a dow but
they don't want to reveal that they're
part of the doubt right so how do we
build the dao where the participants
participant list is private maybe even
the number of participants in the dao is
private today all that information is
public it's available on the blockchain
so how do we build a dao with private
participation obviously how do we build
a dial with private voting so the voters
don't have to reveal how they voted on
each proposal today all those votes are
um are public and finally we also talked
about delegations where people can
delegate their voting tokens to other
people to vote so can we do a private
delegation where i can delegate my
tokens but nobody will know who i
delegated my tokens to
yeah so there are lots and lots of
fascinating privacy questions around
these dows uh lots more research to do
and of course all of that has to be done
while complying with all the relevant
local laws yeah so
generally privacy with compliance uh is
is quite interesting from a
cryptographic point of view often that's
done using what are called zero
knowledge proof systems um and that's
why again that's why this area is so
much interesting this is so interesting
because there are so many beautiful
questions to work on and so many
different things to design yeah so i
should mention that some of these
questions are going to be answered
generically by general privacy platforms
like aztec and aleo
and others and so
while we can build custom protocols for
these to answer these questions there
are also generic solutions being
developed to answer these questions and
so in the future we will likely see many
more private dials that are run out
there than we do uh than we do today
okay so that's all i wanted to say about
daos i was going to talk a little bit
about scaling the blockchain
but actually and talk about roll-ups but
i see that i'm actually running out of
time so why don't i just jump to my
conclusions conclusion slide and uh just
tell you kind of my concluding thoughts
and then i'd love to open it to
questions and to kind of hear
hear your thoughts
so as i mentioned i kind of talked about
the science of blockchain here
blockchains basically which is kind of
the underlying technology that makes
blockchain work the science of
blockchain brings together very
different areas of research rights
cryptography distributed systems
economics programming languages
verification and so on so these are
very distinguished very
different uh areas of research that all
come together to make these blockchains
work so it's really quite amazing that
all these are needed together to make
these systems work
um as you can see the air this this this
design the science of blockchain area
generates new problems in all these
areas so there's a lot of room for more
ideas and as i mentioned in the
beginning the community is very open to
new ideas in his face so everybody's
welcome to participate um so hopefully
you you can think about these questions
too and if you have ideas
uh you know we would love to hear about
them
in addition the other thing that's
changing is there's a lot
there's a lot of improvements to the
blockchain infrastructure that's coming
actually not only coming that is
actually becoming available so for
example nowadays it's a lot easier to do
to interoperate between blockchains yes
if you want to send funds or assets from
one blockchain to another this is
becoming a lot easier if you want to
solve what's called the data
availability problem
that is store data in a way that you
it's guaranteed to be available later on
there is general infrastructure now
available for uh doing data availability
so so the problems that in the past
every project has to saul had to solve
for themselves there is now general
infrastructure that makes that much
easier to do and as a result is becoming
much easier to develop uh better and
safer blockchain applications yeah so
that's that's another uh big changes big
change that's happening in the space in
the the development effort is becoming a
lot simpler thanks to all this new
infrastructure
so despite all of these developments
there are lots of open problems left to
think about there are lots of challenges
in particular i'm sure you you hear a
lot about all the
thefts that are happening in the
blockchain space where uh there are just
economic losses where uh projects due to
bugs due to social engineering they just
lose funds
and so there's a lot of interesting
questions around how uh to make that
better
there are still questions around scaling
the blockchain that uh that remain and
so there's still many many challenges uh
to work on by far this area is um still
quite young and there's a lot of
opportunities uh to make to make an
impact
okay so i think i'll stop here and as i
said i'm very very happy to take any
questions i hope you enjoyed the talk
and i look forward to seeing you in a in
a future talk
so thank you all thank you very much
everyone
thank you so much dan thank you it's a
fascinating area of you know studies and
everything that is happening in the area
so thank you so much there were so many
questions coming in uh if you have some
more questions you should go and submit
them in a q a box so for you dan there
are few clarification questions about
the dow treasury and one of them was on
the
user end so
like since the contributors are blinded
like how you as a submitter can
guarantee that your funds actually go to
a specific dell
that's one question and the other one is
on the other side like how do you
actually specify which private dollar
receives the donation then like how do
you oh yeah great
excellent these are these are terrific
questions um
so let me jump to that uh to that slide
so
yeah yeah so these are terrific terrific
questions um
right so what happens is basically the
dao manager is going to publish this
public key on a website so say i create
the constitution dao
what i'll do is on the constitution
dials website i'll say this is the
public key that you should use to send
funds to the constitution dialogue yep
and then anyone can download this public
key and when they want to send the funds
they'll basically as i said they'll use
the public key to to create some some
sort of a blinded version of the key
and then that will be used to push the
funds onto the uh dial platform yeah and
once the funds are available on the dell
platform no people will know that
those funds were contributed to the
platform but they wouldn't know which
dow on the platform received those funds
now the dow manager has a secret key
yeah that's the whole point there's a
secret key that only the dow manager
knows and that secret key allows the
down manager to come to prove to the
contract that these funds belong to this
dao and therefore the contract is
authorized to use to release those found
funds to the down manager so you can
sort of um so the down manager can
actually use a secret key to just look
at all the incoming transactions and see
which ones are for the dao
for its own dao and which ones aren't so
dumb manager will very easily tell
you know what the current balance of the
dao is just by summing up all the
transactions that came in
and then once it knows the total sum it
can ask the contract to release those
funds to it using its secret key but
what's interesting is without the secret
key everything looks just like noise
without the secret key you can't tell
which funds went where
and as a result this basically uh gives
you the privacy the private treasury
that you'd like to uh that you'd like to
run and again i didn't want to go into
too many technical details here but if
you want to see the technicalities of
how this works you know please check out
this uh this post where we explain kind
of the the cryptographic mechanism
that's used for this
this is based on diffie-hellman tuples
and what's called the diffie-hellman
random self-reduction
so it's actually very i think it's a
very cute cryptographic mechanism that
makes this all possible so yeah thanks
for asking the questions a great
question
great thank you so much and there was a
very positive comment about your answer
uh what do you think are the main
barriers for the deployment of dao and
maybe if you think about emerging
markets and you know some other areas
outside of the us like what do you think
about that about the deployment outside
well it's actually quite easy to deploy
dows there are there's infrastructure
actually that will make it possible for
you to deploy a dial quite uh quite
easily yeah so depending on the dao you
want to deploy
um you can find the right infrastructure
uh and use that infrastructure to deploy
the dao for example if you want to
deploy an investment dial there are
companies out there that will make it
easy for you to create the dial manage
the investments manage the treasury and
so on manage the votes and so on uh so
it's actually not difficult at all to
deploy it out this is why there's over
six thousand six thousand of them
already deployed
now
one of the issues is again how do you
run the governance yeah so how do you
decide who can vote what can what can
they vote on and so on and so forth so
that's very important to sort of specify
at the beginning when the dao is created
you want to specify exactly what is the
power that the dow members the dow
members have so that's that's also
something that needs to be done and then
after you create your dao the
kind of the the the interesting part is
actually attracting members right how do
you get people to know that your dab
exists how do you get people who believe
in the mission of your dao to actually
become members of your dao
and so that's more of traditional
marketing um and so you know you would
have to do some marketing work in order
to make that happen um and that's
actually i have to say that that one of
the hardest parts is basically making
sure the people who are interested
in the goal of your dao become familiar
with your doubt
and then finally once people don't join
your your dao
now you have a bunch of participants in
your dao you have to manage those
participants you know participants often
have a lot of um
requests they might not agree with
everything that you do and so there's a
there's a this is actually called the
participant management uh question and
so there are um
typically often daos will hire people to
do participant management and they will
coordinate um coordinate among the
participants and kind of uh resolve
disputes and so on
so all yeah all that requires people and
a lot of these daos actually literally
have employees working for them and
again it's one i mentioned this in the
talk but it's one of these fascinating
things where you have a program that's
running on a blockchain that program
hires people and then it pays them a
salary um to do to do their job yeah and
uh of course
you know if they if if something
something goes wrong and they don't do
their job properly then the dow can vote
to maybe replace them by somebody else
and so on and so uh yeah so there's a
lot of uh work that happens behind the
theme to make the actual dial function
seamlessly it's quite a lot of work if
you're interested in looking at um
specifics of dials one of the
one of sort of the
one of the large dials out there that's
actually run quite well is called the
maker dial
and you can actually look at look at the
decisions they run through you can look
at the
mechanics of how the dial actually runs
everything is public and so that's just
an example of one dao that you can learn
from to see how that actually works in
the real world it's yeah it's quite
quite fascinating to see how this
actually operates
yeah thank you so much
thank you so much and you covered uh you
know the private dow treasury and now
there are some questions about the
privacy on blockchain isn't it against
the actual basic idea of the blockchain
and maybe if you look outside of dell
like you know like why would companies
like be actually interested in privacy
and how they can actually achieve that
oh yeah so that's a very good question
too so so really in some sense the fact
that everything on the blockchain today
is public
you know it has some benefits because we
have transparency we can see exactly
what's happening uh and we can see how
the system kind of evolves and operates
so that's kind of a on the plus side on
the minus side you know complete
transparency also means
that it can't be used for a lot of for a
lot of applications um just to give two
examples you know if companies you know
if companies want to use um
cryptocurrencies to manage their supply
chain right so maybe you know maybe i'm
building a car like say ford is building
a car and ford wants to pay its supplier
supplier for tires
if they did that on a blockchain
basically everything would be public so
everybody would know exactly how much
ford is paying for tires for their cars
which is typically something that
companies want to uh want to hide right
so if you're so if you're trying to use
this technology for managing supply
chains
you know your entire supply chain will
be public to the whole world everybody
would see exactly how much you're paying
for your parts who your suppliers are
and so on this is typically things that
companies don't companies don't want to
reveal to the whole world and as a
result they simply can't use public
blockchains for this for this purpose
today
similarly you know another another
problem
is you know if companies wanted to pay
their employees salaries in crypto today
that's quite difficult because it would
mean that everybody's salaries is open
and public for the whole world to see
and again often people would prefer
their salaries not to be public and so
there is definitely a need for privacy
uh in in the blockchain ecosystem i
think i mentioned that there are a
couple of companies going after the
public the privacy aspect of um of
blockchains and so companies like aztec
aleo that i mentioned down here they're
building sort of general privacy
platforms that run on a public
blockchain and yet um the transaction
data remains remains private yeah so i
often refer to this as running
private transactions on a public
blockchain and this is actually where
this whole area of zero knowledge proofs
comes in you want to prove that a
private transaction follows all the
rules of the blockchain but you want to
do it in such a way that doesn't reveal
the contents of the transaction that's
exactly what zero knowledge proofs are
and you know we talk about that quite a
bit at quite a bit of depth in the in
the course um in fact this is kind of
one of the i think one of the most
exciting areas in in cryptography in
recent years and so um the fact that it
has these tremendous applications to the
world of blockchains is kind of
remarkable so if you want to learn more
about um
how these are knowledge boost works
sometimes they're called snarks as
urinal snarks um
you know we devote quite a lot of time
in the course to that and so that's
that's that's a good resource
uh yeah so there is a way to do things
more privately and um
um yeah we'll see more of these
applications
uh you know come come along
yeah so i'll leave it up thanks again
thank you thank you so much
uh there were actually a few questions
about a slide you showed with the chart
of you know employers in specific um let
me try to find it
this way yeah and people are quite
interested and um surprised that you
know bitcoin is so low um like why is
that like they are saying you know
bitcoin is so popular like why is it so
low and why is ethereum so high up could
you like tell us a little bit more
yeah that's a great that's a great
question actually um well look i mean we
can only speculate of course so
you know in ethereum ethereum is a
full-fledged blockchain computer right
you can write anyone can write
applications anyone can deploy
applications on ethereum
i think it's not too surprising that
there are many many developers who
actually write applications and deploy
them on the ethereum blockchain
bitcoin is not quite like that right
bitcoin is more of uh specifically uh
it's specifically designed as a payment
system
it does have sort of a small uh compute
engine but it's not it's it's it's a
somewhat somewhat weak uh compute engine
it's harder to write applications for it
and so most of the developers that work
on bitcoin
work on sort of maybe what we would call
layer two bitcoins things like liking
networks um in others so um
yeah so because you know because there
isn't so much opportunity for deploying
new applications on the bitcoin network
it attracts fewer developers than uh
than other blockchains but you can see
there's still a fair number what is it
what does this show there around 500
developers uh working on it um primarily
the work as we said is kind of on layer
twos how do we scale bitcoin how do we
make it more efficient how do we make it
faster cheaper uh and so on so there's
still some development work uh to do
there
but the core of bitcoin doesn't change
very very frequently right it's sort of
um one of the attractions of bitcoin is
this sort of a very stable system that
doesn't change much uh over time and as
a result you know the core of bitcoin
doesn't need that many developers so i
think that's why you see the graph the
numbers for bitcoin being this low yeah
i agree it's a very very interesting
fact i should mention by the way that um
you know there are a lot of people
actually interested in the in the kind
of the left side of the graph sort of
what are the upcoming blockchains that
are relatively young in attracting a
large number of developers if you want
to see that uh just take a just search
for the report from electric capital i
just took one graph from the electric
capital report but the report goes into
infinite details about um about the
developer analysis so if you just look
at their at the report you can kind of
zoom in on this part of the graph and
see what's happening with the younger
blockchains and which ones are
attracting more developers than others
again it's quite interesting
and
definitely useful data
thank you so much down uh and very last
question do you have any recommendations
on like you know what to follow what to
watch for like what to read like how to
learn more and i know you mentioned
courses but like what's your go-to place
if you want to learn more about what's
happening right now
oh go to place well what can i tell you
i mean uh i'm going to
advertise our conference again
so if you want to learn about what's
happening in the space come to our
conference you know the conference by
the way is going to be
live streamed so you don't have to be
there in person um you know we'll
advertise the live stream it's free and
open to anyone you can listen to the
talks the talks basically are these are
this is a technical conference technical
the talks are very technical focusing on
the technology behind blockchains um and
uh yeah you can see exactly kind of what
are the most recent ideas what people
are working on what their con what the
concerns are with the technology and
yeah so i would definitely encourage you
to maybe listen to the live stream
and you can participate
either remotely or in person it's a free
conference everybody's welcome to attend
oh yeah somebody's asking for the link
for the conference uh very good i should
have put the link here that was my
mistake uh i think if you just search
yes
oh thank you yeah it's uh
cbr.stanford.edu
sdc22
yeah so thank you for uh pointing it out
but also if you search for it on google
you'll find it right away
yeah and the conference will be recorded
i'll put the lectures up all the
lectures up on the conference website
great thank you so much dan thank you so
much for taking the time to do this
thank you everyone who had a chance to
join us um yeah i hope you have a
wonderful day evening morning whenever
you are thank you have a nice day this
was fun thank you thank you all for
coming and thanks petra for running this